David it's lovely to see here at
collector mania today if there was an
award for world's worst wedding planner
it would be sitting on your shelf at
home right now yeah what did you think
when you first got the script for the
red wedding I thought this is going to
be fun but I knew a new world from
Season one or the first series and so I
knew what he was about nanu he was a
ruthless man but you know he exists in
the ruthless world and it's the kind of
world where if someone makes a promise
I'd better keep it otherwise there'll be
some kind of retribution and so I mean
he's he is calculating and he's hard but
he has to be it's a harsh environment
that the series existed and it's kind of
kill or be killed and and I want to
think about it I think well if someone
promises to marry your daughter and then
reneged on the deal it it tends to the
worst actually get around that you're
you're a soft touch and you can be
mucked around with and he doesn't want
to be that man so I mean his um his
methods are probably a bit harsh of him
so he's he wouldn't win the in the tact
and diplomacy award certainly but he's a
hard man he's got all these kids he
wants to get married off because they're
all on the payroll I mean got about
thirty seven forty odd children and a
lot of daughters and there just has to
get them out of the house and get them
married off and so and then clearly
finding it very hard and so I can kind
of actually I can't say I can sympathize
with him of course not but
it's it's if you're playing someone like
that you can't just say okay this is
just an evil guy you've got to find take
into account the environment and the
background of the whole story and why he
does what he does and but he is he is a
very very ruthless man and great fun to
play and I
I enjoyed every I probably enjoyed it a
little bit too much actually than is
healthy for one but yeah so when when I
got the script for season 3 I thought
wow this is going to be great fun but we
had a terrific director called American
director called David Nutter who
directed Emmy award-winning episodes of
The Sopranos and many other things in
America and and so he took a whole week
to film like the massacre scene hope I'm
not getting fur there are a few people
out there who who haven't seen it yet
and say I don't want to know because
I've got it taped but I've had a lot of
quite interesting responses to it you
know from more the kind of best
reactions you had so far oh people just
saying I can't forgive you for what
you've done you know and the people
winding their car windows down well I
won't repeat really but it's all in kind
of in a good humor it's from real
diehard fans who have seen some of their
favorite characters just get wiped out I
know it's like the same Valentine's Day
Massacre and
[Music]
and I say we took a whole week to film
the scene because of a lot of lots of
blood about a lot of arrows and
but lives and it was just a bloodbath
and I had to watch it for the whole week
and just look like I was relishing it
what was your reaction when you saw it
on the screen how did you react to red
wedding well I just thought that David
had directed it so well and I thought
wow this he's gotta come back this guy
I'm still waiting to hear but I gather
he does come back at some point
so I'll be I'll be ready but I think
there's some divine retribution waiting
for wall there somewhere along the way
or not maybe it might be one of those
things where because I think what my
kids said was um if if that can happen
to the stark so it can happen to anyone
so it's not so it's not a story where
you think all the good guys will win
through in the end and they can't get
rid of sons own son so it means only all
the characters so it adds that element
of suspense to the whole story if if
anyone can be just disappeared
the moment's notice what do you think's
left for the stocks now there's only a
few of them left on the desire and
that's bran and Rickon Oh as well as
Walder would say I don't know and I
don't care he's got his own problems
he's got a lot of daughters to marry
Arthur theny is yours oh he's got his
own problems a lot of daughters to marry
Ozzy's got a lot on his plate yes yes
and an awful lot of cleaning up to do
cleaning up fill for that you need some
professional services I think oh yeah so
I think in probably Dino rather
something need to be called in
so that's product placement sorry Clara
so we spoke to you recently he plays
blackfish he must take the most
appropriately timed toilet break in any
TV show ever
Game of Thrones and he said to see you
did an amazing job because you had to as
you say you're filming every week and
you had to that scene where you
introduced your daughters and the
various members your family over and
over and over again for all the
different angles how was that because
there's so many names to remember that
was we did that I think in a day and I
did 17 takes it was a four-page speech
and that was my first time I come back
in series 1 so thoughtful
thank you very much so we we went over
in a little bit because of course it has
to be covered by different shots on
every everybody has to be coming a lot
of people in the room so the camera a
lot of cameras set up and I asked the
continuity girl after that is how many
times did I do that today she's in 77 so
yes a lot of names to remember but
that's what that's what we do and that's
a I've done enough Shakespeare and stuff
and over the years know that
what you've got to do is just learn it
well before you get into the shooter
don't leave it til the studio day
otherwise you've got plenty of other
stuff to think about the kisses as
cameras and cables and other people and
there's you if you leave it to the last
minute to learn that you can be you can
be in trouble so I I always try and get
it all under my belt before I before I
go into the studio so not only will I I
know what I'm doing and who I'm saying
it to that but I can I can have a bit of
fun with it because you can it's more
it's more relaxing when you feel
confident about the words not that I
felt totally confident because I still
have a few I still forgot the odd autumn
now and again but we just we just did
this again you know I think that's
entirely forgiven but given the number
of doses you've got everything yes yes
and we had one of my daughter's fainted
during the filming because there the
heat from all the candles it must have
been about 100 candles in there big ones
and it got a bit warm and you know as
you seen my costume is there's a lot of
fur and leather about yeah so it was
because they were all ready for a bit of
fresh air thing any people with fans
cooling you down don't you right yes yes
yeah talking about fans a different kind
of family we used a prize or how
surprised were you at the kind of level
of dedication at Game of Thrones fans
have because for example in the red
wedding you've got will champion his
driver for Coldplay wanting just an
extra role in the show huh yes yes well
I had no idea until he was in the room
and someone said you know that is up in
the top gallery and I thought and he'd
taken time off from the band rehearsals
permission to come over huh
I don't know if he and someone said he
paid for the trip himself he just wanted
to be an extra so the director said well
we got to be up in the gallery might as
well give you a drum so he played the
drums and perfect for Sirius Watchers
you know he's there with his beard and
he was such a lovely guy he just wanted
to be in Game of Thrones and we were all
very honoured you know incredible I mean
they're great fans including will
overseeing what would you say you need
to survive in Game of Thrones and do you
think Walder Frey's got what it takes
well I hope he has because I'd like him
to come back a lot more so I hope he
doesn't have an early death or anything
I don't know I don't know what happened
but I think you certainly need an amount
of ruthlessness and and determination
and making the right choices and siding
with the right people and making sure
the Alliance's that you make of the
right ones because if you if you backed
the wrong horse you could go by yourself
headless or whatever talking about
striking deaths in the show obviously
wanting you back as Walder Frey but if
you had to go out in the show we've seen
some amazing death scenes how would you
like to meet your maker on Game of
Thrones I think maybe hung drawn and
quartered because I've never seen
anybody hung drawn and quartered either
either of course in real life or on film
but there was a lot about what about in
the medieval times and even later so I
think that would be that would be fun I
think it would have to be a lot of CGI
because I wouldn't do that in one take
yeah it's been lovely to talk to you got
a message for your fans out there who
loved the show oh well what can I say if
there's any weddings coming up on the
Vale
so I promise to behave myself and if
I've said to you guys if as long as you
turn up there'll be no trouble okay say
we thank you so much da time thank you
you